'cuba la crisis no da tregua los
agricultores como lázaro sánchez deben
sortear los problemas en los que está
sumida la isla este minuto muy
particular no tenemos combustible es una
situación difícil que es el país entero
no es que seamos nosotros solo que
estamos afectados de 34 meses vamos a la
comida que teníamos que estar sembrando
y que no debemos comer dentro de cuatro
meses nos la vamos a tener la capacidad
de cultivar en su granja se ha visto
mermada además de la falta de
combustible debe encontrar semillas para
sembrar y aparecer en una lista del
gobierno para poder alquilar los
tractores del estado mientras los
agricultores tienen dificultades para
cosechar los habitantes de la habana se
enfrentan a la escasez de alimentos y al
aumento de sus precios el gobierno de
díaz canel aprobó el año pasado 63
medidas que pretendían ayudar a los
campesinos pero esto no ha sido
suficiente para paliar las dificultades
aún hay falta de frutas y de carne de
cerdo vital en la dieta cubana las
autoridades parecen estar al tanto de la
situación la agricultura cubana tiene
dos problemas por no avanzadas el
primero del escaso desarrollo
tecnológico y la imposibilidad de
desarrollarla
aquí hay tecnologías muy primitivas
y el segundo de la carencia de insumos
en el país gasta unos dos mil millones
de dólares anuales en la importación de
alimentos según las autoridades unos 800
millones podrían ahorrarse si se lograra
tecnificar el campo las cifras oficiales
apuntan a que en la isla el 49 por
ciento de las tierras agrícolas no son
cultivadas